now let's shift to
how the media is reacting to this
because i think and i said last week
when this whole story was breaking i
loved this martha's vineyard story
because it is a perfect red pill moment
that stark difference between people who
believe in laws people who believe that
if you say something you do it and
people who just put up signs on their
lawn and actually don't stand by any of
it which is exactly what the people of
martha's vineyard did which is exactly
what the corporate press does which is
exactly what all the democrats do etc
you got it now i usually call msnbc
uh the televised mental institution but
after watching the clip that i'm about
to show you guys right now i want to
call it the muppet news network uh here
they are
talking about ron desantis how can any
of this be legal ellie under florida or
federal law
well it shouldn't be i think we need to
start there first i don't want to you
know give people false hope not every
evil sadistic twisted bigoted racist
thing these people do is illegal some of
those evil sadistic racist bigoted
things are just allowed in this country
this is a country that has cut its teeth
on the force to coerce relocation of
non-white citizens throughout american
history this ain't new when joe biden
says that it's un-american not sorry mr
president this is strangely american
using uh uh non-white people weaponizing
them um and parting them around the
country this is what this country has
done in the past however in this
specific case i think especially when
you look at the migrate the immigrants
sent to marxist vineyard we have reports
that they were lied to that they were
tricked that they were induced with
false promises um to get on planes and
then ship some place where they weren't
told where they were going that to me is
a violation of the federal kidnapping
statutes the legal term of art is
envigling as i you know as i think most
people can kind of their horse sets can
kind of understand if i roll down and
find a bunch of teenagers and i say look
kids hop in my van i'm going to take you
to disney world and i take them to busch
gardens
you know and i take them to old
williamsburg that's kidnapping i didn't
take the kids where i said i was going
to take the kids right so i think that
in this case ron desantis told these
people including children that we taken
to one place boston which would have
services where they would get expedited
pieces where they would be have housing
and then send them to a different place
that is kidnapping and the person that
we need to understand that is
unfortunately at this point not ron
desantis not greg abbott we need merrick
garland
once again to understand that and bring
the full
federal government down on these people
that guy he's half
dr emmett brown from
[Music]
back to the future half what give me
something like half
whatever it doesn't even nothing i say
it doesn't matter you get it it's just
so ridiculous okay so anyway you have
people watching that program not many
people but you might know someone that's
watching that and i think you have to do
what the long line of people did in the
original airplane movie if if someone is
watching that they're they're not well
and you have to line up and you have to
smack them across the face you have to
slap them and and smack some sense into
them that's what you have to do um but
it's interesting because they're they're
in a complete meltdown and of course
it's just racist bigot and it proves
that america's racist and bigot and
somehow biden's even a racist bigot and
the whole thing